shido yoshi ou encore ricky wac et le
vocabulaire des judokas a résonné tout
le week end au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin pour l'occasion le
vélodrome s'est adapté les tatamis ont
pris place pour accueillir le
championnat de france seniors 1re
division qui a réuni près de 800
combattants
le silence est pas au troisième âge
c'est les gens qui ont gravi les
échelons de mines benjamins minimes
cadets juniors seniors donc à la tronche
âge c'est 18 ans je pense c'est quand
même une première au niveau national
c'est le top
on ne peut pas monter plus aujourd'hui
est donc pour nous c'est un honneur
d'une part et puis bah on est ravis
d'accueillir toute la france pour le
beau département des yvelines des
combats féminins et masculins dans cette
catégorie de poids différents les
judokas ont ainsi pu rencontrer de
nouveaux adversaires et tester leur
niveau
j'ai fait deux tours et voilà
malheureusement bas ça s'arrête là bon
je suis quand même content de moi j'ai
39 ans donc pouvoir faire encore les
champions de france bah voila je fais
avec mon mari en plus donc mes filles
viennent nous supporter voilà ce ca que
du bonus
un peu mal au début bah je perds mon
premier combat je suis pas repêché
derrière 17 évinois ont combattu sur les
sept tapis installés pour l'occasion en
plein coeur du vélodrome
une transformation apprécié par les
participants c'est assez rare que sont
complètes comme ça les tapis souris
c'est bien je pense que public ça doit
être assez assez agréable aussi de
pouvoir avoir la vue surtout moi c'est
sympa c'est pas mal ça change
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines au lieu de
rencontres sportives depuis la rentrée
ne va pas s'arrêter en si bon chemin
d'ici la fin de l'année il accueillera
des compétitions de badminton et de
sports de combat